i'd be so grateful to hear how you would
handle your 13 year old child telling
you they are the wrong sex
i'm afraid to make things worse
it depends a lot on
who they are and what your relationship
with them is and probably where you are
like what what cultural part of the
country or world
you are in and
not just who they are now but what their
what their history has been um and what
your history with them has been uh
it also matters what sex they actually
are to some degree um
because uh a girl who's coming to you
a daughter who's coming to you telling
you that they're they're born the wrong
sex they're actually a boy um is more
likely um to be succumbing to a social
situation than a boy who is coming to
you saying the same thing a boy who is
coming to you saying the same thing is
still very unlikely to be
actually trans
and um if it comes on all of a sudden um
that's a good indicator that it's um
that it's a social fiction
um
if you have talked
if you have talked to them before about
um
anything biological or natural or
scientific this will be somewhat easier
i think
i'm just i'm trying to think
it's it's hard
trying to think of what
we would have said had it come to
our
had this come from one of our children
or someone whom we knew well
i think
a you need to recognize that you've been
robbed of
useful tools that a civilization who has
become confused about this
a civilization that has become confused
about this has undermined
your parental authority and i think this
is part of you know people are
there is
lots of talk of grooming and lots of
talk about the abuse of that
term but there is something strange
about society suddenly insisting that it
has the right to tell your children all
kinds of things about sex sexuality
gender
etc and
so a
you're not failing because you don't
know what to say you've been put in an
impossible situation
were it me i would you therefore want to
know what is in your child's head newly
from other sources besides you yeah yeah
i think the thing that i would say and
again i'm not telling you that this is
sufficient
right maybe nothing is but
i think the thing that i would say is
you know
there is a long history of people
who have reached that conclusion
and some of them
turn out to feel that way over the long
term
but there is also a very long history of
people
having that sense
and it going away and them being glad
that they did not act on it right the
number of people for whom dysphoria
resolves is very high and so
i think the point that the point that
you want to to drive home to your child
is
the last thing you want to do is take
this thing that you feel very strongly
at this moment and make permanent
decisions based on it because most of
the people who might have done that are
glad they didn't because it simply
resolves
maybe again depending on your
relationship with your child and who you
both are and
what other family you have and
everything
um this is this this feels
very much like at least a part of a good
response um
it's it's hard for children to
understand time and it's hard for
children to understand permanence
but
um
i'm thinking about that dr seuss book oh
the places you'll go
which is about
how much opportunity there is everything
is ahead of you like you you open one
door
and maybe you shut it behind you but
look at how many more doors are ahead of
you
and what you don't want to be doing
when you're young
is
um
closing doors permanently that you don't
have to
right and
we make lots of choices and they
they open and close doors variously but
presumably at 13 your child has been
through phases
and probably had um some activities that
they enjoyed for a while and no longer
do
um or you know
things things like that and
if you were to say to them when you were
really into rocks
and
you could have made a decision then
um to become a geologist for sure
maybe this is maybe this is the wrong
example right but um
you probably would have wanted to do so
then and yeah you're older now and you
feel like you know everything now but no
one ever knows everything about what it
is that they're going to want to do
and one of the things for instance that
people want to do later that many people
don't think they want to do when they're
young
is have families of their own
and
if
you
were to act on believing that you are
born the wrong sex
there's a very good chance that one of
the many many doors that would shut for
you is being able to have a family of
your own someday
i say that stepping out now of trying to
act as a parent who i've never met
talking to a child who i've never met
um
i never
i don't know if that would have landed
for me
um i was a tomboy i never thought i was
a boy but i was
gender non-conforming on so many
different levels
and it wasn't because of that
that i also just didn't think about
having kids i didn't think about
marriage i you know have the love of my
life who i found early
and that's amazing but i didn't for me i
didn't have the princess fantasies the
wedding fantasies the marriage fantasies
the family i i didn't have any of them
oh you didn't i really didn't and
um
the point that i got pregnant was a
surprise to both of us
hey zach
but um
but we had but but we had also long
already talked about we will want to
have kids but you know by my late 20s
yeah i think we i think we do i think
you know we we do want to have that but
that was a long time after 13. yeah at
13
um you say to a kid you know what if
what if you want to have a family one
day maybe that doesn't land at all maybe
it does for some kids it will there are
a lot of girls in particular who are
really thinking very much of that as
part of their identity at that point um
but you you know you know you and you
know your child and you will know what
kinds of things matter to them and what
they are sure they care about so deeply
and probably they won't care about in
five years just because that's how
things go
and um are certain of now and probably
won't be certain of in five years things
like this because that's the way things
go
and what things won't land as much but
there there are likely to be many
many ways in
um around the sort of theme of
i want to see you expanding your
possibilities i want to see you be
everything i as your parent want to see
everything you could possibly be and
have as many options as possible and
this may feel like an important real
thing right now but it will shut down
your options and it will close doors for
you and you will have a very hard time
escaping from a decision that you want
to make or a series of decisions that
you want to make right now
so i have another another thought i
think this is an important
topic it's worth
the time
when you are young
you are often under the mistaken
impression
that you are involved in the and this is
part of the problem with not having
rights of passage is that you believe
that you are
sort of in the adult world already and
you know especially you're on social
media in the same place the adults are
battling stuff out yeah and the point is
you may feel
that
you have no idea how to do how to become
relevant how to do something important
that will matter over your life and i
think you know we all
wondered about that as young people and
you don't realize that in fact it would
be very very unlikely as a teenager to
do anything that would be significant in
terms you know you could set yourself on
a path but it's very hard to produce
anything as a teenager that ends up
mattering and in fact i used to say this
to our college students too
which is you are not in college to
produce stuff the chances that you will
write something in college that will
matter in the world is pretty low
the chances that you will upgrade your
mind so that you are capable of writing
things that matter is potentially high
it's at least much higher and so that's
the thing you should be building the
tool that's what you're doing and the
things that you're producing are
practice right
but if we don't have rights of passage
and so you sort of feel like oh my god
the adult world is full of stuff that
matters and
some of my peers are doing things that
certainly seem significant people are
paying attention and people are paying
attention the point is what could you do
right now that would suddenly make you
relevant
and the answer is this is something you
can do to make yourself relative
relevant instantly you will become the
focus of a debate over what's right and
whether self-determination this that and
the other and it's fiction right you're
being lured into adult consequence
levels yeah like severe adult
consequence levels yeah right it's not
like
becoming addicted to a drug which you
can then become unaddicted to like
that's a that's an adult thing and it's
very very serious but obviously it's not
the same level of serious as i would
like to decide today as a 13 year old
that i don't want a family
right that's potentially irreversible
and so
somehow i think what we need to do is
convey to our kids that they are not
in the place where they need to be
worried that they are falling behind the
relevant people they're not supposed to
be
attaining relevance yet and that that
pressure is dangerous
yeah
it is very dangerous and so somehow
trying to help your child find their
joy
and you know it's too young for them to
be expected to know their passion they
may have lots of ideas and they may have
no ideas about what it is they think
they're interested in and both things
are fine
um but they can find joy you can find
joy at any age and i think
in middle school in modern weird middle
school there's not a lot of joy in
general
um but i think especially post
during covid it's not post coven
um right now
with the last two years behind us there
is so much less joy than there was
and
grabbing attention has replaced
experiencing joy as
a primary motivator i think and if you
can help your child find
find joy then
then that may well help
[Music]